rush limbaugh reshaped the public square
by forging a path for conservative media
but now that square is being
increasingly squeezed by tech oligarchs
now if you think the classical left
would be upset about corporate
monopolies they used to be
but they aren't so why is that of course
while former president trump is banned
from platforms like facebook and twitter
big tech hasn't lifted a finger to
prevent the ccp from spreading
anti-american lies
someone who has thought a lot about this
is jd vance author of hillbilly elegy
and he joins me now jd um
why do you think the modern left is
suddenly
okay with uh the concentration of power
and a few corporate uh entities
well i think unfortunately it's just
very cynical right they realize
that the big tech oligarchs are actually
on their side
and where they used to complain about
corporate power now they recognize that
corporate power is being used against
their enemies in this case
uh president donald trump and his voters
and so i think they're more than willing
to cozy up to those people if it gives
them more power which it does in this
case because those companies really do
control the public square in this
country
well one thing that also is kind of
shocking i
like your opinion on it is last night
when joe biden
essentially just blows off the
difference between the united states and
china by saying well there are cultural
norms that are different
with the way they treat the uyghurs and
the way that he i loved how he said
well president xi just thinks unity of
thought
is important like what what happened to
liberals standing up for human rights
like divestment in south africa that was
a
that was a big issue for liberals in the
united states and they made a big
difference there
wha what happened yeah well first of all
i wish they were so deferential to our
own founding fathers who of course they
parse
every single one of their words and hold
everything against them
but of course was just super deferential
to z to g
uh i i think a fundamental corporations
in america
are increasingly more invested in the
chinese government than they are in
their own country
and what that means for us as
conservatives is we've actually got to
do something about this you know i think
we've gotten so used to big business to
corporations being on the side of the
right
uh that because of china because of the
woke left they're increasingly on the
side of the left and we have to do
something about it we have to recognize
that they're not our friends anymore and
that should inform the way that we think
about public policy it's a really big
departure
but i think it's an important thing for
us to recognize so we can move forward
and actually
solve these problems and make it
possible for people to express
themselves
and be conservatives without fear of
getting fired or censored well president
reagan understood that you had to
isolate the former soviet union
peace through strength and all that and
that kind of went out the window when
wall street decided they were going to
you know make a lot of big bets ipos and
and otherwise in china a lot of folks at
national review and
uh the journal and a lot of big
conservative outlets
they kind of went with the globalist
perspective and they lost the people
trump came along and said doesn't have
to be this way
and now he's suddenly shut off twitter
and facebook and
and they're relishing uh squelching his
freedom of speech
yeah that's exactly right and of course
it's not just about president trump it's
also about his voters if you were a
supporter if you're one of us
75 million people that voted for trump
in 2020
you recognize that the censorship that's
directed against him
can be and has been directed against you
either through firings either through
shadow banning or twitter just making it
impossible for you to post
and so these things influence and affect
the broader public discourse in this
country and i think we just have to
recognize like you said
wall street maybe was on the side of
america in the 1980s
it's not clear that it's on the side of
america in the 2020s and
we got to wake up to that fact jd great
to see you tonight thank you so much